ukraine says it has retaken part of a
key eastern city where some of the worst
fighting against russia continues also
in the east russian guided and unguided
missiles are said to be
causing widespread destruction and
casualties in the crucial donbass region
a kremlin spokesman says russia will
continue its military operation in
ukraine until all of its goals have been
achieved mts taeyab is in odessa with
the latest mtas good morning
dana everybody good morning well we're a
hundred days into this war and six and a
half million ukrainians have now fled
the fighting but for those who remain
they remain as determined as ever
as fighting rages on across ukraine
the nation marked a grim milestone
there are three words that we have been
fighting for for 100 days president
zielinski said
peace victory
ukraine
with so much of the country already in
ruins and so many displaced from the
fighting peace feels a long way off
we're 15 miles from the nearest front
line and even then this is what a
russian strike can do
still there's no shortage of support for
ukrainian forces this battalion is
responsible for getting hot food to the
front line it's where we meet alexander
trooper who before the war was a chef so
basically you were living in sweden yep
living a nice life as a chef yeah and
you saw the war start and you came back
yeah
because i'm ukrainian ukraine for
ukrainian
feeding hundreds of fighters every day
is a herculean task but juprine says
making borscht ukraine's hearty national
dish is the least he can do this is
delicious
[Laughter]
despite being outgunned and outmanned
what ukraine hasn't been is outwitted we
were given rare access to the top secret
headquarters of its drone army known as
the idol rozvidka unit where volunteer
warriors attack russia with the click of
a mouse
lieutenant colonel
technology is fundamental he says we
can't fight a symmetrical war with
russia so we have to act smarter
arosvidka drones were able to stop this
40-mile russian column dead in its
tracks as it attempted to enter keeve
since then the unit has made strike
after strike
the brains behind this model of attack
drone are former architects alexei
shimoituk and alexander gorban the old
logic oh program
[Music]
it's our design this is ukrainian yes
this is ukrainian
now that ukrainian resolve is
extraordinary but the odds remain
stacked against him in fact just this
morning russia claims to have shot down
a ukrainian passenger military plane and
targeted a weapons store jeff
mts thank you very much